un merveilleux vaisseau de métal et de
verre qui est dû à l'architecte Adrien
fenzilbert et vous n'envoyez ici vous
n'en découvrez qu'une infime partie un
diè environ elle sera ouverte au public
demain je vous disais la Villette il a
fallu 9 ans pour transformer ce lieu qui
était au départ un abattoir qui n'a
jamais servi en cette gigantesque Cité
des Sciences et de l'Industrie ces
choses faites et le président de la
République a inauguré tout à l'heure la
Cité des Sciences et de l'Industrie hl
ch la Geode une bouée d'acier poli
entouré d'eau elle est le symbole de
cette Cité des Sciences et de
l'Industrie inauguré ce soir à la
Villette par François mitteran c'est le
premier projet de musée cité
scientifique au monde mise en chantier
il y a 15 ans lorsqu'elle sera
totalement achevée elle doit offrir
165000 m Carr aux visiteurs deux fois le
centre Georg Pompidou pour savoir si je
deviens
sour vous parle parabole du son
Ling d'or or du parfumeur autant de
gadget destin au plaisir du visiteur
mais on trouve aussi ici de quoi
satisfaire l'apprenti scientifique de la
préhistoire à l'an 2000 la visite de ce
soir éta placée sous le signe de la
comète de que rencontre cette nuit la
sonde européenneoto François mit avait
choisi cette date pour célébrer en somme
deux expériences scientifiques
étonnantes